hey let's gum bros my name is Peter Pan
welcome back to me Shawn would put smart
for Oh what the hell
Jonas haven't you got a patient that
needs you
no you can't just barge in here that
Chris Rock is that right it sounded like
him
all right skank it not a came to
Christmas squalor Jonas is a curry had
the nicest room on the ship
the good doctor deserves gosh she just
works so hard what is it you do Zachary
huh
besides [ __ ] Jonas oh okay fine
Rand let's just you do nothing you cower
and you whine because you don't have to
take that Zachary yes a curry you gonna
take this stay out of this look at you
showing some backbone there we go
well whatever you're gonna do Randall no
I'm not gonna do [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
useless miss it stops now time to earn
your keep yeah go on get them talking
what we're we're the rest of supplies
the bags with the ammo hey shouldn't
keep your finger on the tree don't tell
me how to hold a [ __ ] gun
oh [ __ ] was a curry maybe she does know
better than you please know you're gonna
hurt someone yes Zachary I know what I'm
doing wrong he really doesn't then put
the gun down I don't think she's taking
you very seriously come on I need a
location now that's it careful don't get
you close to her now
please we all need to calm down just
take a deep breath okay talk to us I'll
stay calm if you do Hey
who's in charge here you or her huh
uh-oh answers talk to me
stop so don't Oh Sam
Greg don't it's okay you leave her alone
you want to threaten someone threaten me
Last Chance eccrine [ __ ] do something
stop dammit
Zachary now who's taking things too far
I did outside well that was completely
pointless awesome oh oh
well we broke the mirror before right
okay let's cut out a zip ties with it
good old classic trick you just got oh I
shake my whole screen just got a shake
shake shake hey that was pretty good oh
oh [ __ ]
lay em down can you delay them down huh
I can't be comfortable find something to
stop the bleeding
it's gonna be okay Greg I don't think it
it may be a corker sorry God
hey please help me
come on Greg come on don't do this oh
isn't there a doctor just here a second
ago
how will he do without you not if not a
fake it here oh no you are you are great
oh my god he just [ __ ] died holy Sh
he's gonna walk her eyes he's gonna walk
her eyes he's going to turn Sam
he's gonna it happens fast we don't have
a lot of time I'm gonna need your help I
can't I can't I just need another second
please you can do it you can mourn all
you want later like Jesus Christ get him
off me he just I just need more time my
god can you be more annoying about it
hey good job look what happened I don't
know why I'm doing this but the game was
like hey you should do this
oh we're gonna bash his [ __ ] skull in
that's that's cool hey it's me bear all
right good night sweet prince
la bete horrible oh come on
Jesus Christ have some [ __ ] courtesy
right in front of her
all right now you can mourn oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ] yeah what do you mean what the [ __ ]
what happened to him what are you saying
I didn't do you think that matters
you killed him it was accident I swear
that was not an accident no I don't I
don't give a [ __ ] please oh please Lord
ago you're full of [ __ ] just give me a
turn please you're not leaving this room
you son of a [ __ ] this is one of those
choices it's not gonna help if we kill
him she's gonna make things more
complicated
it's this [ __ ] serious
oh really
well what what wait why oh my god
seriously already we all got demons
honey and I seat [ __ ] up [ __ ] my time
or she started with that habit early huh
but you you're a whole different animal
caged up just itching to get out I seen
it in your eyes you're chiller
that's what you do oh you don't know
what I can do
Oh about she did she just hit us okay
cool
that was episode one of into deep with
that Walking Dead Michonne ooh ah I have
a have a lot of thoughts this is a nice
tune
so Walking Dead it's been such an
amazing game play series at season one
was amazing season 2 was great not as
good but it was still really really good
ah now I dabble into Game of Thrones and
and now we play this and it's going down
let's just say that like I'm not
enjoying it as much as I enjoy the first
two and I think it's because it all
these new characters we don't have we
haven't spent a lot of time with them so
we don't really care that much about
them I didn't like it wasn't sad when
anyone died here and it's just also now
that uh you play the first couple games
you realize that your choices they don't
really matter that much in the game I
would say a season one and season two
they pretty much end up the same uh just
some choices in the end that changes it
so it just feels like like when I choose
the dialogue for example it feels like
does it really matter what I pick I just
kind of go with what I think makes sense
to say but I don't feel like I'm really
part of the story I feel like I'm more
like watching a movie which takes me
away from from the experience a little
bit it takes me away from the immersion
and I really felt that playing this I
got really bored at a couple points just
because there's so much dialogue and I
don't really care that much about anyone
I'm sure it gets better and more
interesting but overall I didn't really
love this episode I don't feel like oh I
can't wait for episode 2 or anything
like that um I don't know do you agree
with me or do you do you are you pumped
I don't know
so I can't say for sure if I'll actually
do episode 2 or not I'm I'll see from
you bros response and I'll make a
judgement from there but I feel like I
would really want to focus on I don't do
that many series anymore and I think I
really want to choose my cards more
carefully about it and pick series that
I I actually really want to play and
there are I have a list of a few that I
add I'd probably rather want to focus on
so yeah you know or you could just see
this as kind of like a good distraction
while we're waiting for season 3 because
I'll definitely play season 3 so maybe
we should just wait for that and said
it's what I'm thinking I don't know but
thank you very much for watching this
with me I hope you enjoyed it either way
it wasn't wasn't bad I live like we
enjoyed and I'll see Bruce in the next
one as always stay awesome press